juin 2017 des agriculteurs italiens
locke des camions dans le port de bari
la télé italienne et sur les lieux ces
camions transportent du blé canadien que
les producteurs locaux jugent moins 5 e
le relais italien depuis cet événement
les importations en provenance du canada
sont en chute libre
si les italiens en ont contre le blé
canadien c'est à cause de cette pratique
interdite en italie
la pulvérisation au glyphosate quelques
jours avant la récolte
pour cet agriculteur des prairies le
glyphosate est un outil indispensable
on cultive 5000 hectares et on a huit
culture différente cette année
alors c'est très important d'arriver à
les récolter rapidement le traitement
après récolte nous aide parce qu'ils
accélèrent la moisson spezza l'herbicide
est autorisé pour se débarrasser des
mauvaises herbes comme chez jack lang
oui mais il procure un autre bénéfice
comme le blé n'est pas génétiquement
modifié pour résister au glyphosate
il meurt plus besoin de le faucher et
d'attendre qu'il sèche comme autrefois
la céréale est prête pour la récolte à
une date précise
sauf que cette pulvérisation pour
accélérer la maturation du grain elle
non homologué au canada et c'est elle
qui laisse le plus de résidus dans les
aliments en italie saverio debonis est
agriculteur et sénateurs il est l'une
des forces à l'origine du soulèvement
des fernie en 2017
l'organisme de défense des consommateurs
qui la fonde et fait analyser les pattes
des huit plus grandes marques italiennes
elles contiennent toutes des traces de
glyphosate
mais aucune ne dépasse les limites
permises ce qui ne rassure pas
l'agriculteur possible qu'est ce que dit
la science c'est qu'il ne faut qu'une
faible dose pour avoir un effet
endocrinien une action d'interférences
sont les hormones il n'y a pas de dose
maximale minimale la recherche
indépendante ici en italie a démontré
que la présence de cette substance même
à faible dose causera du tort car il
s'agit d'un perturbateur endocrinien
le géant barilla qui maintient que les
pâtes sont sécuritaires
d'ici tout de même de revoir à la baisse
ses propres limites de 10 parties par
million à 0,1
c'est 100 fois moins les exigences
envers nos fournisseurs sont de ne pas
utiliser de clips faisant avant la
récolte est de livrer du blé dans lequel
on ne détecte pas cette substance
malheureusement les producteurs
canadiens ne sont pas capables de
rencontrer cette exigence depuis toute
cette histoire
les exportations canadiennes sont passés
d'environ un million de tonnes par année
à moins de 300 milles une baisse de 70%
une situation qui fait dire à certains
même dans le milieu agricole qu'on
devrait revoir lusage du glyphosate
après ricol mais catherine finalement
les italiens ont racheté un peu de blé
canadien cet automne
oui ça recommence et peu à peu après des
mois où c'était carrément à zéro là les
exportations
ça commençait un peu à l'automne pour
dire que les italiens ne sont pas
autosuffisants en blouson fois une très
bonne récolte cette année c'est le
premier producteur de pâtes au monde ils
ont besoin de blé est rangé du côté du
canada les associations de producteurs
martèle le message auprès de leurs
membres
il ne faut pas utiliser le glyphosate
pour faire mûrir artificiellement le blé
et il faut également mentionner que le
blé ce n'est pas la seule culture d'une
main on salue la risée way quelques
jours avant la récolte là il ya
également l'avoine l'orge les lentilles
et les pois le lin entre autres donc
c'est un peu pour ça qu'on en retrouve
des résidus dans la nourriture notamment
le gruau alors vous nous présenter tout
ça en fin de semaine samedi
oui à la semaine verte on lance le bal
de la semaine glyphosate à radio canada
donc la semaine verte à compter de 17h
samedi 12h30 dimanche mais également à
l'épicerie mercredi soir à enquête
jeunes soit mais aussi à la radio aux
années lumière bien sûr on va suivre
tout ça avec intérêt merci beaucoup 92
ans prix